The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So today we
move to a topic I really like.
It's the beginning
of the applications.
So the particular
application that comes first
will be springs and masses,
a pretty classical problem.
But what we're looking
for is how do we model it,
what's the main
framework to look
at a whole series of problems.
So this is number
one in the series
and it's the most
straightforward.
Let me draw it with four
springs connecting three masses.
And let me fix both ends.
So this will be a
fixed-fixed picture.
So the masses have some weight.
The weight pulls
the springs down.
When there was no weight
acting they were not stretched.
The masses will
stretch the springs.
And the question is
how much do those,
we're looking for
the displacements.
How much does mass one go down?
Mass two?
Mass three?
And of course, essentially
the displacement
here is zero and here is zero.
I don't know if you can
imagine these masses have acted
so that the position before
gravity was turned on
was somewhere up here
and then it came here.
So this moved down
by a distance u_1.
Let's use u for
the displacements.
So if I look at
this main picture
here I have displacements,
movements, u_1, u_2, u_3.
Now what happens physically?
Important in every
one of these examples
to see what's
happening physically.
Of course, this one
moved down by some u_2,
this one moved down from its
total rest position to u_3.
These are not oscillating.
Next week they'll start
moving, time will enter.
Here I'm just looking
for a steady state.
They come to rest, they stretch.
So what's your feeling of what's
going to happen here, somehow?
The displacements look to me
like they'll all be positive.
What's the key
equation going to be?
That when this moves down
it will stretch that spring.
Hooke's Law will say there's a
force, the spring pulls back.
The spring pulls
back with a force
proportional to the stretch.
So u_1, u_2, and
u_3 are movements.
Here is a key question.
What's the stretching
in spring number two?
So this is spring one,
two, three and four.
How much does spring number
two stretch? u_2-u_1.
A difference is coming in there.
So let me put that up here.
So stretching or elongation,
I'll use two words,
elongation I'll say
sometimes because that
starts with a letter e.
So these are the
elongations in the springs,
in the four springs.
It's the amount the
spring stretches.
Or what's the opposite
of stretching?
Compression somehow.
Looks to me like this
last spring, at least,
is going to be compressed, and
I'm not sure about the others.
So we've got four springs.
And each one has a stretching
or compression, an elongation.
And then there's a link then
that you already told me.
That e_2 is, just
from the picture,
e_2 is the difference
between u_2 and u_1.
Because the lower mass
goes down by distance u_2,
the upper mass by u_1 and spring
is stretched by the difference
u_2-u_1.
So that's a first key fact.
So that expresses somehow
a fact of geometry.
Of sort of the way
things are connected.
The material properties
of the springs
have not got into
the picture yet.
But now Hooke's Law brings
them into the picture.
By stretching a
spring that produces
a force that pulls back.
So we get, can I say,
forces in the spring.
And let me give those a
name w. w_1, 2, 3, and 4.
And then the link between
the stretching and the force
that it produces is--
So that's somehow
where the properties of
the material come in.
So I have to say, what are
the properties of the springs?
So this will be
Hooke's Law, this step.
Hooke's Law for this
particular application.
And so I have to say these
springs have spring constants.
So I haven't completed the
description of the problem
until I've told
you about springs
themselves and the masses.
So the spring constants will
be c_1, c_2, c_3, and c_4.
And now what does
Hooke's Law say?
Usually this physical law in
the middle we keep it linear.
Of course, we all understand
that if these springs were
enormously stretched
the elastic property
could become non-linear.
It could become plastic.
The first law always
has somebody's name.
Was the person to see
that in some range
of small displacements, so
I guess that's the answer.
We're speaking here about
small displacements,
small stretching up
to the point where
Hooke's Law continues to hold.
And now what does
Hooke's Law say?
It says that each
force in the spring
is proportional to the
stretching of the spring.
You could say it's-- a diagonal
matrix is showing up here.
The vector of w's, the vector
of forces in the spring is
a diagonal matrix C, which
just has these numbers
on the diagonal,
...c_4, times the e's.
So of course I'm going to write
that in matrix notation as W
equals a matrix C times e.
So there in the
middle is the physics.
The material properties,
the constitutive law.
C can stand for constants,
for constitutive law,
later for conductances.
It's the place where
the material enters.
And now how do we
complete this picture?
In the end we have to
bring in the masses.
Gravity is the external force
that's making things happen.
We need a force
term from outside
to move us away from zeroes.
And that will be the
downward forces f_1, f_2,
f_3 on the three masses.
So I plan to complete this
picture with a force balance
equation on the
masses, on each mass.
When I use the word
framework there,
this is what I
was talking about.
I guess what I want
to say is I really
have found that this way
of describing, modeling
the problem is successful
for so many applications.
You have somehow a geometry, a
step which'll involve a matrix
A. Then you have a physical
step which involves a matrix C.
And then finally you
have a force balance.
In a way this force
balance or its analog,
the analog would be
Kirchhoff's current law.
We'll see that for networks.
Flow in equals flow out.
Force on one side equals
force on the other.
If we're talking
about equilibrium
we can expect our model to
have an equation like that.
And for me it really helps to
know when a new model comes in.
Like somebody'll
come into my office
with a problem in
chemistry or biology.
But if it fits in
this framework I'll
be looking for a balance
equation, a continuity
equation at the end.
This part was easy and
it's these two parts
that I want to pin down.
Well you told me
how to start here.
So the elongation, so I want
to take this step again.
I want to find the elongations
from some matrix that
multiplies the displacements.
So I'm just
completing this step.
And you told me what is the
stretching in spring two.
Again, do you mind
just saying it again?
The stretching in that
second spring, the amount,
it's made longer by the action
of gravity was? u_2-u_1.
u_2-u_1.
So e_2 will be, a minus one here
for u_1, a plus one and a zero.
That will be a typical row of
this matrix, the displacement
stretching matrix,
you could say.
Now what about the
stretching in e_1?
What's the stretching in e_1?
Only u_1.
Because essentially
it's u_1-u_0 but u_0
is set to zero by the support.
So we only have u_1.
Because that multiplication
just gives us-- So e_1 is u_1.
e_2 is u_2-u_1.
e_3 is what?
The stretching in
the third spring.
What is it? u_3-u_2.
So I need a one for u_3
and a minus one for u_2.
And the stretching
in the fourth spring?
What's the stretching
I've sort of, and you have
too, mentally given a plus sign
when the spring is
extended and a minus
sign when it's compressed.
Plus for tension,
minus for compression.
So since I fixed that
one, u_4 was zero, so what
do I have in this last row?
Just minus u_3.
I guess what I'm saying
here is that if we
get a systematic
approach to problems
then we know we're looking for
a matrix that connects these.
We're looking for the material
constitutive law that does this
and now we're
looking for this one.
We kind of know where we are.
What to look for.
And so this matrix is the
matrix I'm going to call A.
So this is e=Au.
Well one more step to go.
And that will be the
force balance step.
So now, what's the
equation for balance?
The external forces
are the masses.
Well, I guess to
get the units right,
it should be mass times g,
the gravitational constant.
So let me put external
forces f_1, f_2, and f_3.
The three masses will be
m_1*g, m_2*g, and m_3*g.
So those are the
forces from outside.
Now it's the balance
equation I'm after.
So this is in this position.
It's in equilibrium.
And what does that tell us?
That tells us that the
total force on this mass,
so I'm going to
take each mass, it's
like a free body
force diagram here.
I'm looking now at that mass.
I'm saying what forces
are acting on it
and I'm making them balance.
So what equation
will that give me?
So let me write that.
This is now the force
balance equation.
Force balance at each mass.
How much force is pulling up?
What's the force pulling up on?
So this spring is
pulling upwards.
And it's pulling
upwards by w_1, right?
Just getting these
letters right.
The w's were the
internal resisting force,
reacting force in the
spring. w_1 is pulling up.
What other forces are
acting? w_2 is pulling down.
And also pulling down is?
Gravity, m_1*g.
So the balance of forces there
says that w_1, the force up,
is w_2, the force
down, and m_1*g.
And similarly the
next one will have,
the next mass if I look just
at that I see a force up,
a force down and gravity down.
So w_2 will be, well, that's
the pull up, will be w_3+m_2*g.
And the third one, the
force up on the third one
will be the force
down on the third one.
so I think those are
the equations of force
balance written one at a time.
And now, of course I'm
going to write that--
So that's three
equations with four w's.
So I want to write that
as, I want to bring the w's
all to the left-hand side.
Can I do that?
Can I just bring those
over with minus signs?
And make these equal signs.
So now we've got internal
force balancing external force.
This vector of external
forces is the f's and this
is the internal forces.
Now somewhere there we're
going to see a matrix.
So I'm going to write this
equation as some matrix.
Well, let's figure out
what that matrix is.
So its shape is what?
I've got three equations, so I
need three rows in the matrix.
I've got four w's so
I need four columns.
So it's going to multiply
w_1, w_2, w_3, w_4
to give these three masses,
can I call them f_1, f_2, f_3,
just to have a good letter.
We're almost there.
What's the matrix?
What's the matrix for this
final step, the force balance
equation?
I just read it off.
w_1-w_2.
I think I've got that.
w_2-w_3.
Tell me what the second
row of the matrix
looks like to give me w_2-w_3.
zero, one for the
w_2, minus one.
Good.
And for the third, the
final row? [0, 0, 1, -1].
So that completes
the third piece.
If I'd given you the problem
as I did, drawn the problem,
described it, you
know that there's
going to be a connection
between the external forces
and the displacements.
But what I'm trying
to say is a good way
to see the connection is to
see it in three simple steps.
The simple step that gets
you from the displacements
to the springs.
A second step
within the springs.
A third step back
to the nodes, you
could say, back to the masses.
And of course, the key question
is, what's that matrix?
And do you recognize it?
Do we need a new
name for that matrix?
The matrix in the third step?
So this third step is going
to be that some matrix times
w is f and what's that matrix?
What's the good name
for us to give it?
A transpose is the
best possible name.
If we've given this
matrix the name
A, the stretching
displacement matrix,
the strain in elasticity,
this becomes the strains,
these become the stresses.
But the beauty is,
just beautiful,
that the matrix in this law
is the transpose of this one.
So it's A transpose.
So that's the framework seen
now here for the first time.
So the key point was that
A and A transpose both
appeared but with physical
material properties,
constitutive matrix in between.
So if we put the pieces
together, then we're golden.
And then, let's do an example
to see what actually happened.
So the equations were
e=Aw-- e=Au, then w=Ce,
that's Hooke's Law,
and then A transpose--
or maybe I'll write
it as f=A transpose*w.
That's the three steps.
So in this problem the source
term showed up at that point.
The source term came
from external forces.
I've got three equations.
Now I'm going to put
them together into one.
I'll put them into one equation.
So this w I'll just substitute.
So it's A transpose
w is Ce, and e is Au.
So I have A transpose C Au.
So that's the ultimate.
That's put the whole
structure together.
That's the equation
you have to solve.
This would be called
the stiffness matrix.
And I use the letter
K for that one.
So our equation is Ku=f.
This is our final equation.
Well, we didn't know w.
There are two unknowns here.
Two physical things
that you want to find.
If you're designing a
bridge or a structure
you want to know
the displacements
and then you want to know
the internal forces w.
It's really beautiful.
The two unknowns of u
and w are somehow dual,
we can work with one, work
with the other, work with both.
Oh let me just mention that
the finite element method will
fit this framework and somehow
this name stiffness matrix has
become famous for finite
elements in structures
and then it's just exploded
to appear all over the place.
I guess we should
look at A transpose
C A. We can see
what it looks like.
And also just from the
way it looks there.
So I can write it
out explicitly.
I think we want to.
But at the same time
I can learn something
from just seeing how
it's put together.
What can you tell me
about A transpose C A?
Let's get the shape first.
Just to see the shape
of these things.
The matrix A is what?
What's the shape of A?
It's over here.
Four by three.
And the shape of C was,
three by three is it?
Where have I got, that C matrix
better be here somewhere.
Oh, no, it's four by four.
Four springs.
Of course, it had to be four by
four to do that multiplication.
There's the C matrix.
Four by four, thanks.
And the A transpose matrix?
Three by four, thanks.
So the net result
is three by three.
Good.
So it's a square matrix.
K is a square matrix.
What else can you
tell me about it?
Now we're going to begin to use
some of the, sort of the matrix
preparation.
These matrices are
kind of friends by now.
This is a difference
matrix, somehow.
Right?
The stretchings are
differences and displacements.
That's its transpose.
And then the C matrix,
which is the new thing, sort
of the new guy to appear
today, is diagonal.
Well if I asked you now,
without writing out the matrix,
for one more
property, it's square,
what else could you
tell me about it?
Symmetric is going to be a very
good guess and let's see why.
Why is it symmetric?
How do we show that that?
What do I do?
I take the transpose.
If I take my K transpose, now
I write it as, what do I do?
It's a product of things.
So when I transpose a product I
have the individual transposes
in the opposite order.
So A, its transpose comes first.
C, its transpose comes next.
A transpose, its
transpose comes last.
So that's just the rules
of matrix transposes.
Now what?
Now I'm ready to use the
wonderful fact of what
we've got here.
So what is C transpose?
So notice we wanted a
symmetric matrix in the middle
to be able to knock that T out.
And what is A
transpose transpose?
That's A. We've learned
that the thing is symmetric,
that if I transpose it
I get it back again.
We're going to see
more about that.
But let me do the
multiplication.
So I'm going to
take that, oh, boy.
How am I going to do that?
I want to multiply three
matrices to see what K actually
looks like here.
One question first.
Eventually the solution, the
short formula for the solution,
will be u equal K inverse f.
Right?
So the answer will be u equal
K inverse f in matrix notation
but I'm looking for numbers.
And then if I know u then I know
the stretching. e is A times K
inverse f.
And w is, I'm just going down
the list, is C times A times
K inverse f.
We've got everything.
So that's the key.
This is the key equation.
That's the answer.
Let me ask you about inverses.
What about K inverse?
We took three steps.
Now what if I just ask
you about inverses?
This is K inverse that
we would like to know.
So again, for inverses
I'm going to start this
and I'm going to stop halfway
and you'll tell me why.
If you give me a
product of matrices
and I don't think
particularly much
I'll take the inverse of that
times the inverse of that
times the inverse of that.
And what's the matter with that?
You would say, why not
just undo each step?
Why not find the w's from
the f's and then the e's from
the w's by dividing and
then the u's from the e's?
Why don't we just go
backwards around the loop
rather than what I'm
saying we have to do.
We eventually get this
step across with a matrix K
that does all three at once.
Well sometimes we
might be able to,
but I don't think
we can in this time.
What's the trouble
with A, that I
don't want to write A inverse?
Well I don't say singular.
What do I say here?
Look at this matrix A here.
It's not square.
It's not square, that's right.
So I'm not comfortable, I'm
not willing to write A inverse
when A is not a square matrix.
And this distinction, is
the matrix A square or not,
is the first issue.
It's just the picture.
Let me show you an example
of where it would be square.
May I?
Before I do this multiplication,
can I jump to a-- I'll
change the line of springs
in a way that'll change A.
And let me show
you what happens.
Suppose I take out that spring.
So I've removed
the fourth spring.
It's a line of springs now,
hanging from a support.
It's a perfectly good problem.
It's problem two, but
it's a different problem.
And what's different now?
There is no fourth spring.
If this was my problem,
what would be different?
There's no fourth spring.
So that's gone.
I just have three springs
stretching from three masses.
Then the force
balance is the same.
Everything looks the same
except there's no force,
there's no fourth spring,
so there's no force there,
that's gone.
And of course,
how does C change?
So in my new picture now
I have, let me write now,
A transpose C A. A is
now three by three,
right, I've lost a row.
A transpose is now
three by three,
I've lost a column, that
fourth spring is gone.
And what is C?
Well of course there's
no guy here anymore.
What I'm trying to say is for
this problem the matrices have
become square.
This would be correct.
So this is an especially
nice kind of problem.
It's called statically
determinate.
It means I can determine the
three w's from the three f's.
I can go backwards.
Everything is determined.
The long word for
the fixed-fixed one,
our main example, is
statically indeterminate.
I cannot determine four
w's from three forces.
I can't determine what
these internal forces are
until I put the whole
loop into one matrix K.
So that's like a warning,
and at the same time,
an important separation.
A few nice problems where you
don't have too many springs,
you don't have too
many bars in a truss.
You just have like, the minimum
number to hold it together.
Could be statically determinate
and square matrices.
But here we're not square.
Now I go back.
So that would be fixed-free.
Right?
That example that I just
described would be fixed-free
and we can kind of carry that
along because we know that what
happens is we lose
a row and a column
and a-- c_4 is just not
in the picture anymore.
But now I want to go back to the
fixed-fixed one and finish it.
So that's got a support
down there, too.
Key question, what's
this matrix K?
This A transpose C A. We
know it's a square matrix,
we know it's a
symmetric matrix, but it
would be really nice to
know what does it look like.
What does that matrix look like?
Can I do the multiplication?
So this is going to be K. So
it starts with a three by four.
1, -1; 1, -1; 1 -1.
Then it's got the four by
four, c_1, c_2, c_3, c_4.
And then it's got the
transpose of that, which
is the 1, -1; 1, -1; 1, -1.
With zeroes where I
didn't write anything.
We've got three matrices
to multiply together.
What's going to happen here?
Well, let's see.
I guess, why don't I
multiply that by that?
Can I do that?
So that's like getting
two steps together.
It's going to be
easy because of this.
This is usually an easy matrix.
Often diagonal.
So when I do that
multiplication, so let me,
I'll just copy this guy.
And now c_1 multiplies that
row, c_2 multiplies this row,
c_3 multiplies this row and
c_4 multiplies the last row.
c_1 in that row,
c_2, c_3, and c_4.
And now I'm ready to put
those together into K.
So K will be three by three.
What does it have?
It has c_1+c_2.
And then next to that
is going to be this row
one against column
two, there'll be a zero
or they'll be a -c_2 here.
And then when row one
goes against column three
there's nothing.
Why nothing?
When do I expect to see a
zero in the overall matrix?
What is it about?
So that zero is in
the position 1, 3.
What is it about masses
one and three that
is putting that zero in there.
We kind of expect to see that
zero even before we find it.
If I look at the
picture, what do you
notice about masses
one and three that
is going to produce the zero?
They're not connected.
If I had another spring,
which I could have,
connecting mass one to mass
three that would produce,
I'd have another.
I'd be up to five.
Instead of four, there'd
be a fifth spring.
It would have its own constant.
It would show up.
Absolutely could.
Here we don't have it.
Now let me keep going.
I know from symmetry
that the second row
times this is going to be
zero, is going to be -c_2.
Symmetric as I expected.
What are you expecting on
the diagonal there? c_2+c_3.
That's certainly
the right pattern.
Zero, c_2+c_3.
c_2+c_3.
And what are you
expecting over here?
-c_3 is a good guess.
It's seeing that pattern.
Let's just see it happen.
That second row
times this third guy
will give me zero, two rows, two
zeroes, and then a -c_3, good.
And now we know the zeroes
going to show up here,
the -c_3 is going
to show up here.
And what will show
up here? c_3+c_4.
So we've got it.
That's the matrix K that
controls this whole problem.
Now we check.
It's square, yes.
It's symmetric, yes.
And notice also it's the kind
of matrix we've seen already.
In fact, it's exactly the
matrix we've seen already
Suppose all the c's are one.
Suppose every c_1,
c_2, c_3, c_4 is one.
Then what's the matrix capital
C in that standard case?
C will just be the identity
if these are all ones.
And then I'm only left
with A transpose A.
So let me take that
special case below it.
Special if so this is if C is
I, what matrix do we have then?
Just to see that we have a
matrix that we know about.
So I'm copying this now here in
the case when all the c's are
one.
So if you put all those c's to
be one, what matrix do you get?
You get, yes.
You get the special K.
Right, you get the special.
So the work we did to understand
that special matrix pays off
here.
Because we know how
that matrix works.
And this matrix, well, it's got
four spring constants in it.
But we can guess the
important facts about this one
from this one.
So what are the important
questions about that matrix?
This is my matrix K now.
What would be, we know it's
square, we know it's symmetric.
What else do we
ask about a matrix?
Well, positive definite, that's
the perfect question, right.
And built into
positive definiteness
would be a property that we
mentioned the very first day.
Is it invertible?
What's your guess?
Is that matrix invertible?
Everybody's going to guess yes
because, if you guessed no,
where would you be, the
whole course would end.
In fact, the world would
end because the problem
is correctly posed.
Those displacements are
determined by the forces
and that just says K is
an invertible matrix.
So but how do we see that
it's invertible and, even
more, positive
definite, because that's
the property we now know.
So why is that matrix
positive definite?
Do we want to
check determinants?
We could say, okay,
that guy's positive.
We could evaluate this product
and find that it came out well.
Would you want to do that one?
We could probably do the
two by two determinant.
Could you take that times
that and subtract that?
Let's just write it
above what we would get.
Just to see it.
That number times that
number would be a c_1*c_2
and a c_1*c_3 and
a c_2*c_2 twice.
And a c_2*c_3.
And then I would
subtract off this guy.
So it would knock
out that, right?
And it would leave something
that would be positive.
All the spring constants
are positive here.
We're talking normal materials.
I guess, actually,
people are producing now
really amazing materials
with amazing properties.
And the amazing property is
a material with a negative c.
But that's like-- 18.085
does not allow such a thing.
Right?
All these c's are positive.
And you might guess that the
whole determinant is positive.
But now I'd like
you to tell me why.
So now we can use our
growing familiarity
with matrices to say why is
this matrix positive definite.
Is symmetric, of course.
Positive definite.
Why?
So that's what the previous
lecture helped us to answer.
We've got these
various tests, but what
was the core idea of
positive definiteness?
The core idea was
positive energy.
The core idea was I looked at
the energy x trans-- no, u,
sorry.
Have to call it u
now. u transpose times
that matrix times u.
And there was a reason why that
matrix was, why this number,
it's going to be
a number, right?
This combination will
involve all four of these
c's, it'll involve three u's.
I don't want to write
out that quantity.
It would be, I'll have some
u_1 squareds and some u_1*u_2.
I won't have any
u_1*u_3, because that 1,
3 entry is zero.
But why was this positive?
Where do I put the parentheses.
Where do I put the parentheses
to see that that's positive?
I put them around where?
Around that, good.
And around this?
This is really, since we
now have a letter for Au,
this is really e
transpose Ce, right?
That's e.
This is e, Au, and
this is its transpose.
And now what?
So now we've narrowed
it down to C.
Oh, we can actually
see why it's an energy.
Remember C is that
diagonal matrix.
What will this be?
This is the row of stretchings,
the diagonal matrix of c's,
and the column of stretchings.
And now if I do that
multiplication, what do I get?
Do you see it?
Because the physics
is coming in.
What do I get?
This will multiply that.
So what's the first term
I should write here? e_1?
What will it be?
I only have diagonal.
In other words, I only
have perfect squares
when I look at this thing.
I think I just have c_1*e_1
squared coming from that
diagonal.
That c_1 there,
this e_1 here, this
e_1 there is going
to give me that c_1--
What else will I have?
c_2*e_2 squared, c_3*e_3
squared and c_4*e_4 squared.
And do you remember about
springs and Hooke's Law
and energy?
What's the energy in a spring?
This is a stretched spring.
So the energy in a stretched
spring, what I wanted to say,
this is the sum of four internal
energies in the four springs
but it properly should
have a factor 1/2.
There probably, to really
use the word energy properly,
it should be half of all
this, half of all this,
half of that's the energy
in the first spring,
the energy in the second,
the energy in the third
and the energy in the fourth.
But of course our matrix
point was, it's positive.
It's a sum of squares
multiplied now
by these positive numbers, these
elastic constants, c_1, two,
three and four.
So we know the main
facts about that matrix.
We're really at the
point here of we've
got some problem
formulated, we've
got the essential
facts about the matrix,
it's symmetric, positive
definite, certainly invertible.
Then there'd be the step
of actually computing u
by solving the
stiffness equation.
Say, for example, Professor
Bathe's big finite element
code, ADINA.
What's the big
picture for ADINA,
for any big finite element code?
NASTRAN, ANSYS, whatever.
Abaqus.
There are so many
really good ones.
And they've taken years and
years of work to create.
But if you look to see what
are the elements that go in,
you choose the model, and
we'll see in the next chapter,
in October we'll see what
finite elements is about,
you have the
material properties,
you assemble the matrix K.
That's a key step, is
assembling this matrix K.
And then the final step
is solve the system.
Ku=f.
But it's assembling that matrix.
Now one thing
popped into my head.
Do I have time to
mention it or not?
And there's no class
Monday I think, right?
Can I mention?
Can you hang on one
more second to mention
a really remarkable way to
do matrix multiplication.
You may say, we know
matrix multiplication.
We got it.
Right?
We did it and we got
the right answer.
Can I just show you another way.
And you can like,
see if it works.
I did this
multiplication by like,
I'll say rows times columns.
I took rows times columns.
That's the usual way.
But finite elements and
other, often the right way
is the opposite.
It's columns times rows.
And of course, this
guy's in here too.
You might say, okay, what do
I get from column one times
that number, times row one?
Can you do that
multiplication just mentally?
Multiply that
column by that row.
First of all, what shape
will the answer have?
What shape will the answer
have if I multiply a three
by one times a one by three.
Three by three.
It's a full matrix.
Columns times rows.
And it's a totally legitimate
way to multiply matrices.
That column times
that row will be?
Well you can see
what will it be.
And then the c_1 is
going to come into it.
If I just did those
multiplications,
it would just be that.
And then the c_1
puts that there.
What do I see there?
I see the element matrix.
Do you see that this
is the piece that
involved c_1 in the answer?
Well I guess you'll
see it better
when I do column two
times c_2 times row two.
So I have to add that guy on.
And then I'll leave the other.
What do I get if I do
that column, three by one,
times itself as a
row times the c_2.
I don't know if you see
what I'm going to get.
If you just do that, you'll
see a c_2 will appear here.
And a -c_2 will appear there.
And these will be zeroes.
So this was column
one times row one.
This is column
two times row two.
And third and then the fourth.
But do you see that
this part is telling me
all about the second spring?
This part is telling me, what
does the first spring, the c_1,
contribute to K. This part
tells me what does the c_2 part,
do you see the c_2 part in K?
There, there, minus
there and minus there.
The third part from the column
row would be the c_3 part.
And the fourth part
from the fourth spring
would be the c_4 part.
So that's a way you
won't have thought of.
But it's the way ADINA
would assemble this matrix.
It would not do
that multiplication.
It would do it this
way, columns times rows.
We'll see it again.
So, hope you have a great
weekend and a holiday Monday
that we all happy about.